some news out of washington
this weekend the george preston marshall
monument at rfk stadium was removed now
obviously the team hasn't played there
in decades but it was
a reminder of the fact that the momentum
is moving toward potentially changing
the name of the team we talked last week
about a message that was sent by coach
ron rivera to the organization to the
employees of the organization regarding
things that they are going to do actions
they are going to take and it felt to me
like an invitation for someone to
initiate organically from within the
team itself a push to consider changing
the name a dictionary defined racial
slur so
that that all is pending and we'll see
how many other voices join in on that
but there have been columns by people
like jarrett bell of usa today there was
an editorial board item from the
washington post on friday
and there is that pressure on the team
and this removal of the george preston
marshall monument only adds to the idea
that
that
maybe this is the time and if not now
when to change that name chris
yeah well i i think the pressure is
going to continue to mount i mean this
this fight's not going anywhere as we
saw again this weekend
there's still protesters out across the
country
trying to get rid of symbols that
remind people of bad times or a bad part
of history and i get that you know and
hey i do think the redskins name is it
should be in big trouble it should be
changed sorry that's just the way it is
you know it's disrespectful it is and
you wouldn't go up to a native american
on the street and you know call them
that to their face especially a true
tribal one like we've talked about mike
now when it comes to george preston
marshall i mean are you shocked by this
of course not i mean this is a guy that
was considered like
the biggest racist in the nfl for a long
long time and
people are just sick of those people
kind of being memorialized but go ahead
sorry actively he actively resisted
integrating his team he had to basically
go kicking and screaming he had to be
threatened he had to be leveraged by the
kennedy administration to finally bring
uh bobby mitchell onto the team in the
early 60s and coincidentally and maybe
this is just a baby step toward what
could be coming the lower ball at fedex
field was named for george preston
marshall it is going to be named for
bobby mitchell they are going to retire
mitchell's number he died earlier this
year so maybe maybe the the clues are
out there as to where this thing is
going but uh you know actions are
happening
uh the question is will they stop short
of changing the name
and i
we'll see and we'll see if there's any
pressure that comes from within the
organization at the
vague general invitation of ron rivera
to the employees of the team last week
to suggest things they can do to be part
of this effort to change in this
historic moment of awakening when it
comes to
racism and social justice will it happen
from within and if it does will daniel
snyder heed the call chris
well i mean i wish he would daniel
snyder i mean i know he's an intelligent
man
you know i i don't look at daniel snyder
and the fact that i've been around him
one or two times in my life and go oh
this guy's just evil he's got evil in
his eyes no i don't i don't look at it
that way you know do i agree with
everything he's done as an owner as a
football team no i don't you know have i
liked how he's handled certain
situations no not all of them but i mean
i got respect for the guy and i would
think he would be smart enough to know
right now like hey man
you can make like a real positive
you know impact on society and do
something and show leadership once again
to go hey the time for change is now and
i see that and i'm going to change this
ridiculous redskins name into a name
that is you know more glorifying to
native americans or something more
positive whatever it may be
i would hope he would do that i would
hope he could look at himself in the
mirror and do those type of things but
you know these these days of the george
preston marshalls and confederate
monuments and things like that it's over
it's done it should be over it's it's
it's disrespectful to a huge part of our
country and i don't want to see it i'm a
white american and i got nothing to feel
uncomfortable about racially but when i
used to pass by that kind of crap at
texas i always got like the willies i
was like what the hell is this what are
we what are we glorifying this for
and i just don't like it so i'm i'm all
in for the george preston marshalls and
all that type of stuff to come down and
let's move on with more of a positive
frame of society and not remind
everybody of bad things all the time
the connection to slavery is grounds
enough for making those changes the fact
that a lot of these individuals were
part of an effort to overthrow the
government of the united states right
should be all that we need to realize
that they should not be glorified and
never should have been in the first
place and you wonder what the message
was
to the former slaves and what the
purpose was in glorifying them at all
all right we got it and then wanted a
vote to count we wanted to give them the
three-fifth camp compromise while we're
there and all that crap i i don't want
to get the history sorry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports